when did you know it was gonna be huge
did you see the pilot and go
okay this i'm gonna be doing this for a
while i mean i hate to say that like
because i had never even done a pilot
and i i now know like how
unlikely it is for pilots to go to
series even but
i i maybe it was really it was really
naive of me but like i
you know i was cast on arrow first it
was i did
two episodes of arrow and i was supposed
to do a third episode of arrow that was
going to be a backdoor pilot but
um the character was received so well
they decided to do
a pilot a standalone and i
knew from then i was like well we'll get
a series just because it's the flash
and it like i never thought like it was
never about me it was just about like
i'm so lucky
that i landed this and there's no way
the flash phone at least get
a season one you know right coming off
the heels of arrow
and i mean maybe it was naive of me but
i just i thought
at least you know three to five seasons
felt like a given just because it was
such an iconic character and i was for
sure ahead of myself but i mean
and then meeting tom kavanaugh and being
a big fan of jessie l martin before we
all
came in i mean david nutter called me to
tell me jesse was doing it because he
knew what a big difficult theater
nerd i am right and freaked out and
hannah baker i mean she's done all kinds
of things but like specifically i
remember when i was younger like irving
at sky high and i was like man this cast
is like
insane um yeah i had faith really early
on that it was gonna we would be fine
you